public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
nicole belloubet la ministre de la
justice est l'invité de l'épreuve de
vérité bonsoir madame et merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation au nom de
public sénat des échos de la fp de radio
classique vous répondrez à trois grandes
questions ayant bien sûr très à votre
grand ministère de la justice d'abord
zone de non droit comme la zad de notre
dame des landes bien sûr passivité face
à la délinquance que répondez vous aux
critiques de la droite sur un manque de
fermeté
c'est jean francis pécresse qui viendra
vous le demander deuxième question
quelle réforme de la justice se dessine
pour désengorger les tribunaux vous le
dirai à jérémy marot enfin troisième
question sommes-nous assez protégé
contre le terrorisme comment empêcher
notamment la radicalisation en prison
sujets qu'abordera tout à l'heure mais
qu'at elle à metz mais d'abord une toute
première question d'actualité
un de vos prédécesseurs a donc commis
une très grosse faute éthique jean
jacques urvoas a transmis les éléments
sont probants dans la presse à thierry
solère les éléments de l'enquète
préliminaire le concernant pour des
soupçons de fraude fiscale bien sûr vous
êtes choqués par cette violation du
secret professionnel
c'est une entrave à la justice si vous
voulez moi je ne veux pas commenter au
delà du strict nécessaire cette affaire
qui est en cours mais je reprendrai ce
que j'ai eu l'occasion de dire si les
faire réellement sont avérés
effectivement c'est une affaire grave
très grave en termes de comportement des
tic pour un ministre de la justice
certains bien sûr et donc la logique
c'est que monsieur airways soit
poursuivie devant la cour de justice de
la bulle et que voulez vous le demande
et pour le respect de l'institution
j'imagine le demandez vous le souhaitez
je n'ai pas à lui souhaité ni à le
demander les procédures sont telles que
effectivement il est très probable que
la cour de justice soirée d'un clic soit
6,6 alors une question peut-être plus
politisé et est ce que vous estimez que
thierry solère lui n'a plus sa place
aujourd'hui dans le parti présidentiel
qu'il a rejoint la république en marche
non mais si les mois je ne raisonne pas
de mon de ma position ministre de la
justice sur ces questions là j'observe
une situation je juge qu'elle est grave
et manifestement cela des incidences qui
sont extrêmement puissante je me dois de
réagir face à ces questions là mais je
ne veux pas me positionner sur ce sujet
là j'ai rassure mais vous le comprenez
dans l'opinion à cette affaire jette le
doute sur l'affirmation selon laquelle
les politiques se tiennent à distance
des dossiers sensibles vous même
quel est votre pratique en la matière si
vous voulez moi je pense là aussi une
occasion de le préciser je pense pas
qu'on puisse inférées d'une affaire
particulière et singulière une règle
générale je dis que nous sommes dans un
système où
il appartient au gouvernement de
conduire des politiques publiques et
notamment de définir la politique pénale
et d'informer et d'être informé de
dossiers sont sévères cela il doit
effectivement pouvoir bénéficier de
remonter des parquets et que ses
remontées elles portent soit sur des
affaires qui s'attache à l'ordre public
soit sur des affaires qui concernent des
questions internationales sensibles je
pense airbus soit sur des affaires qui
traite de personnalité particulière bref
ou des affaires d'ailleurs sur la
criminalité financière par exemple qui
font l'objet d'une politique pénale
précise ce sont des remontée automatique
ce sont des remontées qui parviennent à
la demande
non non ce sont des remontées qui
parviennent à la direction des affaires
criminelles et des grâces les parquets
on voit ces informations le la direction
des affaires criminelles ensuite saisi
mon cabinet le cabinet du garde des
sceaux des affaires les plus sensibles
et mon cabinet m'alerte le caser chez
adacore des affaires particulières mais
vous vous le sollicitez jamais de cela
ma formation à vous a réussi très
honnête cela peut m'arriver
mais c'est d'une part franchement très
rare franchement très rares et seulement
seulement dans les situations qui sont
prévues par la circulaire de 2014 qui
listent ces cas et une fois vous avez
des informations vous vous interdisez
bien sûr au nom de l'éthique des grands
principes
certains comportements bien sûr les ces
informations - chambre dispose elle me
serrait ensuite à conduire cette
politique pénale permettez moi
simplement de prendre un exemple non
nominatif mais lorsqu il y à des
informations qui nous parviennent sur
par exemple des questions de viol de
mineure évidemment ces informations ne
parviennent à partir d' affaire
singulière
ce sont ces affaire singulière qui me
permettront ensuite de dégager des
règles générales de politique pénale
est-ce que selon vous cette affaire où
aujourd'hui plaide pour une séparation
définitive entre la chancellerie et le
parquet entre le pouvoir politique et le
pouvoir judiciaire alors d'une part je
dirais de deux choses si vous me le
permettez d'une part au moment où nous
parlons je viens de vous
rires nous avons besoin d'informations
venant des parquets pour conduire et
construire la politique du gouvernement
qu'il s'agisse de la politique pénale ou
bien des politiques publiques pour
lesquels la justice est partie prenante
parce que il ya les deux aspects dont
nous avons besoin me semble utile de
remonter mais en même temps le président
de la république a annoncé une révision
constitutionnelle au sein de laquelle
nous allons encore renforcer
l'indépendance la justice pleine et
entière a dit le candidat en modifiant
le statut des membres du parquet est par
exemple en confiant le pouvoir
disciplinaire des membres du parquet et
un pouvoir renforcé pour leur nomination
au conseil ce faire il y aura bien une
réforme constitutionnelle donc mais sur
la nomination des magistrats
si vous nous confirmez ce absolument
très bien à la suite de l'épreuve de
vérité avec jean francis pécresse le
directeur de la rédaction de radio
classique
bonsoir jean francis vos questions à la
ministre a justifié son soir madame
alors est-ce que sur la sur la zad de
notre dame des landes mais aussi sur les
questions de lutte contre la délinquance
la droite vous accuse d'une forme de
passivité qu'est ce que vous lui
répondez que c'est inexact mais notre
dame des landes par exemple il ya une
zone de nos zones de véritablement de
non droit il ya eu 168 décision de
justice qui n'ont pas été exécutés qui
autorise l'état à mettre les travaux des
travaux en marche
comment est-ce qu'on peut accepter que
ces décisions de justice quand on est
garde des sceaux n'ait pas été exécuté
alors moi je vous répondrai en deux
temps en tant que garde des sceaux
évidemment je suis d'une certaine
manière mais pas seul bien sûr dans ce
cadre garante de l'état de droit et donc
évidemment garante du respect des
procédures liées à cet état de droit sur
la question précise de notre dame des
landes et c'est le deuxième temps vous
le savez un rapport a été remis hier au
gouvernement
ce rapport évoque un certain nombre de
pistes
le président de la république et le
premier ministre se sont engagés à ce
qu'une décision définitive soit prise
avant la fin du mois de janvier
cette décision définitive ne concernera
pas que le lieu d'implantation du futur
aéroport mais également le traitement
des éléments sont attachés et donc la
question de la zone de la zad
alors écoutez on verra entendre bruno
retailleau qui est sénateur de vendée
très partisan on le sait de cet aéroport
de ce nouvel aéroport et lui il réagit
déjà un éventuel renoncement à notre
dame des landes ce qui semble d'ailleurs
être la thèse privilégiée par l'ensemble
des journaux ce matin
ce serait une faute bien sûr une faute
contre la démocratie
on demande à consulter des centaines de
milliers de personnes pour finalement
ignorer leur vote
ensuite il ya l'état de droit l'état de
droit c'est les 178 décision de justice
l'état de droit c'est en même temps un
lieu les assiste en réalité qui ne
respectent pas la loi de la république
et donc
mails macron doit répondre à cette
question en france est ce que le
chantage à la violence paye ou non est
ce qu'il donnera le dernier mot aux
ultra violent ou est-ce qu'il donnera le
dernier mot aux décisions de justice et
au citoyen honnête je n'ai aucun doute
sur le fait que le président de la
république souhaite évidemment le
premier garant de l'état de droit
mais si c'est le chantage mais il n'y a
pas ici de questions de chantage il y à
des décisions à prendre ce que les
français attendent c'est d'une part
qu'une décision soit prise sur cette
question là et qu'elle soit exécutée
c'est ça que les français attendent et
donc je crois que le président de la
république ne reculera pas ni le premier
ministre d'ailleurs ne reculerons pas
devant cela ils prendront une décision
et cette décision sera mise en oeuvre
dans l'ensemble de ses composantes sur
leurs épaules je le répète ici et
d'ailleurs si votre question porte sur
la zad quelle que soit la décision
forcément il y aura une décision prise à
propos de la zaoui alors justement est
ce que cette décision du président de la
république elle doit être prise avant ou
après la décision de faire évacuer cet
add autrement dit comme il ya une forme
de prise d'otage de la décision publique
est ce qu'il appartiendrait pas ou
président de la république de décider
d'abord de faire évacuer cette za thd de
manière à prendre une décision en
liberté de liberté pensée j'allais dire
que la situation actuelle ne lui
interdit aucune liberté de penser et ne
le prive d'aucune ça c'est quand même
peser sûr je ne crois pas je
notre-dame-des-landes il n'y avait pas
cette occupation est jeune voilà je
pense l'aéroport là sans créations et
des très anciennes
elle est très ancienne vous le savez
très bien et je pense que le président
de la république dans la situation dans
laquelle nous nous trouvons concerne
complète conserve totalement sa liberté
de pensée entre les deux options qui
sont proposées par le rapport dont l'une
des deux est d'ailleurs assez nouvelle
que lé le choix qui sera fait là
l'interdît nullement une décision sur le
reste des parts à mal sur ce que les
les corses les nationalistes corses qui
ont ont donc remporté les élections
locales les élections territoriales le
le week-end dernier appel le cas des
prisonniers politiques
est ce que ces prisonniers il
faux les amnistiés comme une demande où
est ce que vous accepteriez de les
rapprocher de la du département alors si
vous voulez dans cette situation là nous
n'avons pas d'à priori mais nous
examinons les situations au cas par cas
nous les examinons au cas par cas
compris la musique nous nous examinions
la situation en fonction des peines qui
ont été prononcés pour le moment
n'évoquons pas la mystique mais en
fonction des colonies en poupe et randy
alessandri qui ont assassiné le préfet
erignac faisant nous sommes sans vous
envisageriez une amnistie
je viens je serai jamais là pour s'être
mal exprimé a exprimé jeudi que pour le
moment la question de la miss teen
n'avait jamais été envisagée d'accord je
suis en train de vous dire que nous
examinons les situations au cas par cas
autrement dit genou sommes récemment
interrogé sur la situation d'un détenu
que nous envisageons de rapatrier en
corse parce que les conditions le
permettent
mais nous examinons les conditions de
sécurité dans lesquelles ils pourraient
être accueillis en c3 j'en ai pas vous
donner ici les trois que j'ai je ne
serais pas ici de nous mais en c3 où je
me sens si près mais nous sommes aussi
précisé je vous dis simplement que nous
sommes récemment un débat beaucoup
d'autres toute façon pas y sont
stationnés sont très peu nombreux à me
lire m'a donc nous nous interrogeons au
cas par cas sur la situation qui nous
permettraient ou non d'effectuer ce
rapatriement en corse mais nous restons
dans le cadre de la peine qui a été
prononcée dans le cadre de la
possibilité d'effectuer ce rapatriement
dans le cadre d'un rapprochement
familial
bref comme pour l'ensemble des autres
détenus nous traitons s'est situé en
biens détenus corses en seraient
concernés cette réflexion à 4 ou 5 4 ou
et lorsque les les nationalistes corses
demande une modification de la
constitution de la ve pour prendre en
compte les spécificités de leurs de leur
île est ce que c'est quelque chose que
vous n'êtes que vous seriez prêt à
envisager
s'ils voulaient cette réflexion elle
existe déjà puisque la corse fait
l'objet d'un traitement singulier
et parmi nos collectivités territoriales
le président de la république l'a encore
a fait observer que pour les
collectivités territoriales
nous pourrions prendre en compte des
situations de différenciation pas
seulement d'expérimentation mais de
différenciation et donc de mon point de
vue mais je ne suis pas seul à réfléchir
à cette question
de mon point de vue il n'est pas exclu
d'envisager une différenciation à partir
du moment où on respecte le cadre
constitutionnel dans les eaux on
sortirait d'une république une
indivisible
mais d'ores et déjà donc c'est déjà
c'est le cas lorsque vous regardez la
situation de la nouvelle-calédonie
lorsque vous regardez une discussion
votre tour mère madame c'est pas c'est
pas assez pas là quand ce qui se passe
ni un thème la france métropolitaine il
faut t'il y compris en france
métropolitaine la métropole faut-il
penser de manière uniforme
est ce que les principes qui ont guidé
la constitution de notre état ils ont
aux environs de napoléon est ce que ces
principes là doivent demeurer sans
jamais être infléchie est ce
qu'aujourd'hui légalité puisque c'est ça
le coeur même est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'égalité ne doit pas être conçue non
pas comme une égalité formelle mais
comme une égalité réelle précisément
permettant des différenciations c'est
une question que je vais tenir la seule
la réponse aux questions avec quand même
une attitude assez ouverte 1 de votre
part sur ces questions on le note que
j'en ferai une seconde encore sur la
question corps je remarque depuis
dimanche dernier
il n'y a plus dans la voie des
responsables gouvernementaux de
condamnations formelles lorsque l'on
prononce les termes de prisonniers
politiques corses
est ce que je sais ce que c'est une je
pense que lorsque je passe et il me
semble que lorsque je vous ai répondu
c'est un traitement au cas par cas dans
les conditions les maisons aux moineaux
demain est ce que est ce que vous
lâcheront d'année il me semble qu'à
partir du moment où je parle de
traitement au cas par cas dans les
conditions de droit commun
je réponds à votre question donc oui
vous l'a condamné je réponds à votre
question de la manière dont j'ai répondu
autre sujet enfin vous avez vu
évidemment que la cour des comptes a
épinglé dans un rapport publié hier la
construction de plusieurs établissements
de l'immobilier dans le périmètre de
votre ministère et notamment des
établissements pénitentiaires sous la
forme de partenariats public privé dont
la cour estime qu'ils sont en fait en
ruine e pour les finances publiques et
en particulier pour obliger de votre
ministère je voulais savoir au delà du
passé de ce qui a de ce qui a été fait
parce que c'était extrêmement facile de
revenir sur ce qui est sûr ce qui a été
fait avant mais comment est ce que vous
comptez vous y prendre pour conduire
pour construire quinze mille places
nouvelles de prison dans les dix ans à
venir puisque vous vous êtes engagés sur
deux quinquennats
sous quelle forme est ce que vous les
financerait d'abord moi je dis ici
clairement que je partage les
conclusions de la cour des comptes
donc vous avez vous allez renoncer à ses
partenariats public privé pour
construire les présents et ce n'est même
pas une décision nouvelle puisque déjà
depuis quelques temps nous ne mettons
plus de programmes de construction sous
forme de ppp n'avons pas dénoncer celui
qui est je dirais le plus lourd en
termes de contraintes budgétaires qu'il
est le pp le ppp du tribunal de paris
effectivement pour lequel je crois que
c'est à peu près 80 6 millions d'euros
par an que nous allons payer pendant un
certain nombre d'années
mais nous ne ferons plus de démarches
par le biais des ppp
en revanche nous construirons soit par
la loi mop soit par des d'autres types
de contrats qui nous permettront
d'aboutir à sa déconstruction me
semble-t-il tout aussi les 15000 places
est ce que vous maintenez cet objectif à
l'horizon 2 à l'horizon de dix ans après
l'humain disant absolument
en réalité nous espérons avoir réalisé
dix mille pardons avoir lancé et réalisé
mille places à la fin de ce quinquennat
et puis la suite venant encore et juste
pour terminer nous mettrons en place une
loi de programmation pour la justice
est ce le financement de ces
établissements pénitentiaires sera
assurée dans le cadre de cette loi de
programmation toute dernière question
vous avez vu que depuis quelques
semaines beaucoup d'avocats se plaignent
de ce que des tribunaux construisent des
boxes fermés par des cages en verre ou
voire par des barreaux est ce que c'est
une pratique qui vous choque
est-ce que vous souhaitez y mettre un
terme alors nous sommes actuellement en
contentieux puisque effectivement des
avocats ont sollicité des tribunaux nous
avons répondu en fait ce qui a justifié
cette démarche
la justification et les liées à la
sécurité que nous voulons assurer pour
les magistrats pour les personnels des
tribunaux et puis également à la
prévention d'éventuels risques d'évasion
à ma connaissance il y à une
jurisprudence relativement récente la
cour européenne des droits de l'homme
qui précise que ces dispositions là ne
porte pas atteinte à l'article 3 de la
convention qui vous savez qui porte sur
la dignité des personnes
et donc nous attendons évidemment les
résultats du contentieux qui est en
cours que je crois auront lieu à la fin
du mois pour voir si nous poursuivons la
démarche dans laquelle nous étions
engagés uniquement dans les fins de
prévention d'évasion et de protection
d'accord ben écoutez la première
question que vous a posé les gens
francis a fait l'objet et bien d'un
sondage pour cette émission madame la
ministre
sondage opinionway et comme chaque
semaine sur l'action des manuels 20
contre contre la délinquance est ce que
vous êtes satisfait 39 % de oui mais
comptant 57 % donc apparemment il va
falloir convaincre les français mais
peut-être que la question se pose plus
pour le ministre de l'intérieur je sais
paris aussi ceci membre d'un
gouvernement donc donc j'assume
évidemment et la responsabilité et les
défis je crois que la mise en place de
la police de proximité de la police du
quotidien
les démarches autour des chantiers de la
justice que nous lançons pour faire en
sorte nous l'espérons que la justice
soit rendue plus rapidement j'espère que
tout cela contribuera à rassurer nos
concitoyens c'est justement le thème que
nous abordons maintenant dans la suite
de l'épreuve de vérité merci beaucoup
jean francis et nous accueillons jérémy
marot de l'agencé france-presse
désormais l'épreuve de vérité avec les
filles bonsoir jérémy soir michel
bonsoir madame belloubet alors vous
engagez effectivement une grande réforme
de la justice se découpe en cinq
chantiers on va les rappeler brièvement
donc il ya l'organisation territoriale
de la justice la simplification de la
procédure pénale la réforme de la
procédure civile également il ya tout un
volet numérique sur lequel on reviendra
et puis une réflexion sur le sens et
l'efficacité de la peine alors dans le
cadre de cette réforme je crois que vous
avez lancé une grande consultation c'est
ça se termine demain
oui enfin elle se termine demain aux
chances ou les remontées que nous avons
demandé aux différentes cours et
tribunaux doivent nous parvenir demain
nous devons ensuite les analyser et nous
avons promis la restitution de ces
chantiers pour le 15 janvier
la restitution de cette consultation
ensuite je me livrerai à une phase
d'analysé de concertation avec les
organisations syndicales de magistrats
elle et les conférences etc qui nous
mènera jusqu'à la fin du mois de février
de sorte que je puisse déposer les
éléments législatifs qui serait
nécessaire pour la loi de programmation
j'en parlais tout à l'heure qui devrait
débattu au printemps alors on va quand
même pouvoir disposer dès ce soir
d'éléments sur ce prêt fond monsieur
nettement je ne suis pas sûr d'en avoir
dès ce soir vous évoquez les mêmes
magistrats avec lesquels vous travaillez
eux sont déjà vent debout contre ces
chantiers alors pas de course mais nous
avons beaucoup de réponses qui nous sont
remontés donc soit ils ont dénoncé cette
consultation ont dénoncé la consultation
10 on n'a pas eu assez de temps pour
répondre
le formulaire est biaisé les questions
sont biaisés qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
leur réponds je réponds deux choses
d'abord que l'idée n'était pas de
refaire un travail théorique et
conceptuelle sur l'édifice
aux axes de réforme de la justice ces
travaux ont été faits depuis très
longtemps il ya une conférence de
consensus sur les peines ya eu des
rapports il ya énorme sur les prisons il
ya énormément de choses n'avons pas de
besoin de reprendre cela donc en fait
nous interrogions les praticiens du
droit c'est les magistrats nous
interrogions les avocats et c'est sur ce
qu'il ressentait un certain nombre de
propositions comment il pouvait se
positionner quelle idée nouvelle le cas
échéant ils pouvaient nous suggérer mon
idée c'est d'être pragmatique c'est à
dire vraiment de déverrouiller les
choses pour que la justice soit rendue
plus rapidement être le justiciable soit
placée au coeur de notre préoccupation
donc ce n'était pas une fausse
consultation c'est inexact de dire ça je
n'ai rien de prédéterminer mais tout le
travail théorique existaient déjà et à
partir de maintenant on va analyser ses
consultations et faire des propositions
comment vous vous qualifiez riez à
l'heure actuelle vos relations avec les
magistrats est ce que la relation déjà
détériorées alors qu'elles auraient été
moi je suis extrêmement naïve et où est
incorrigible optimiste je ne considère
pas que ma relation soit détérioré nous
avons des relations qui parfois sont des
relations évidemment épidermique
ce qui est bien naturel dans un milieu
humain mais moi j'ai toute confiance
dans le travail que je peux conduire
avec les magistrats
je parle du point de vue de notre
réflexion sur le monde de la justice
alors si vous voyez ce matin encore je
recevais les bateliers
nous sommes dit nos quatre vérités ou
notre heure de vérité
et puis nous avons avancé alors si on
rentre dans le détail de ces cinq
chantiers l'organisation territoriale
pour commencer il ya une inquiétude si
je te commencer par ça parce qu'en
réalité pour moi c'est plutôt la
conséquence de tout le reste
il ya beaucoup d'inquiétudes dans le
pays sur ce thème là règlement est ce
que des tribunaux vont fermer c'est la
convention non je répond très clairement
non mais ce n'est pas la première fois
que je réponde on vous dit très
précisément aucune juridiction ne
fermera mais ce qu'à l'intérieur des
juridictions on peut voir moi je veux
bien que l'académie française se soit
penché on peut imaginer que certaines
chambres par exemple ferme à l'intérieur
donc j'ai jamais dis que rien ne
bougerait c'est à dire que je pense s'il
voulait qu'on a peut-être à réfléchir à
partir du moment où on va puissamment
numérisés et nous aurons le financement
pour ce faire à partir du moment où on
simplifie les procédures
à partir du moment où on essaie de
recentrer les magistrats sur le coeur de
leur office forcément on peut pas partir
du moment où les greffes c'est en tout
cas ce que je souhaiterais sont soulagés
d'un certain nombre de tâches
matérielles ont peut-être envisager de
regarder comment nous travaillons
ensemble et si ce travail peut être
amélioré mais cela ne signifie en aucune
manière que l'exigence de proximité de
la justice qui se trouvent dans les
lieux actuel des tribunaux ça ne
signifie en aucune manière que cette
exigence là sera combattue et que nous
fermerons des tribunaux cela ne signifie
tu en occultant t'imaginer que certaines
chambres ferme soit déplacé viens de
vous dire je ne sais pas comment le dire
je viens de vous dire non et pour tout
dire
comment expliquez vous le répéter alors
à l'envi et pour vous même vous même
vous mêmes ne
débat ne me comprenaient pas donc c'est
sans doute il ya des douze rapports
territoire de 2015 moi j'assume et les
rapports de la cour des comptes
dois-je assumer tout ce qui a été écrit
pensée ou fait avant moi
oui d'une certaine manière pour la
continuité de l'état mais non en termes
de décisions politiques dont je le
répète nous ne fermerons aucun tribunal
voilà pour la carte judiciaire mais il
ya d'autres éléments que l'on connaît
déjà qui relève de la philosophie de
cette réforme a révélé hier réforme de
la procédure pénale qui est civil elle a
encore quelques inquiétudes sont émises
peut-être pourrez-vous y répondre
notamment sur la procédure pénale des
magistrats craignent un renforcement des
pouvoirs de la police à leur détriment
et là encore l'affaiblissement qui
revient souvent du rôle du juge
d'instruction est ce que c'est le sens
de cette réforme et qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez répondre à ces inquiétudes
alors je peux comprendre les inquiétudes
ce que j'ai voulu avec mon collègue
gérard collomb c'est qu'effectivement
nous puissions travailler ensemble sur
toute la partie de la procédure qui
concerne donc la phase d'enquêté que
nous travaillons en lien avec les
services de la police et de la
gendarmerie
parce qu'au fond ce que nous nous disons
c'est qu'il est important que quand un
justiciable dépose une plainte que
celles ci puissent suivre de manière
totalement dématérialisées et
simplifiées un processus qui la
conduisent jusqu'au juge aujourd'hui ce
n'est pas le cas il y à des ruptures
il y a donc des travaux supplémentaires
qui sont conduits par les uns ou par les
autres
les procédures au stade de l'enquète
sont extrêmement complexes et oblige de
manière très concrète extrêmement
concrète à reprendre et à répéter x fois
les mêmes choses c'est sur cela que nous
travaillons mais cela je tiens à le
préciser ce n'est en aucun cas en aucun
cas dont le but de déposséder
juge peut-être même au contraire est-ce
que cela renforcera son regard
alors madame la ministre vous voulez
privilégier des solutions de médiation
n'est ce pas des solutions alternatives
à la prison notamment je vous propose
d'écouter vous allez pouvoir réagir à ce
que dit laurence buisson qui est la
secrétaire général du syndicat de la
magistrature
qui est elle peut-être comme vous vous
allez pouvoir nous le dire ou pas une
militante des peines alternatives
nous ce que l'on réclame au syndicat de
la magistrature s'est véritablement
faire de l'emprisonnement une réponse
marginal dans le cadre du droit pénal
je crois que pour cela il faut de
l'ambition politique il faut une
véritable volonté d'agir et donc par des
dépénalisation par des modifications de
l'échelle des peines mais surtout pas
par la construction de nouvelles places
de prison
alors est ce que vous êtes en phase là
ce que vous voulez vous aussi la
question est quand même c'est le direct
la sphère de la prison une réponse
marginal je ne pourrais pas du tout ce
monde là je n'emploierai pas seulement
l'arrivée ni même l'idée c'est à dire
que pour moi la peine de prison
c'est une peine qui doit être utilisé
comme tel mais à bon escient
à côté de cette peine mais construites
comme des peines également autonome
nous devons développer d'autres outils
nous devons développer les travaux
d'intérêt général et vous savez
d'ailleurs à cette fin que j'ai
missionné un parlementaire et un chef
d'entreprise pour voir comment nous
pouvions booster les conditions de
réalisation de cette peine nous devons
développer le placement sous bracelet
électronique nous devons développer tout
un ensemble de peine que je ne souhaite
plus d'ailleurs appelé peines
alternatives à la prison mais peinent
autonome
c'est à dire que ce n'est pas une
alternative le magistrat doit voir
lorsqu'ils jugent en face de lui une
gamme de peine qui correspondent à une
échelle de sanctions différentes et il
doit vous pouvoir piocher dans ses
outils mm complètement noël dans la
lignée de madame taubira j'ai envie de
vous dire
alors ça c'est le jeu c'est très bien
que ça vous ferait très plaisir que je
dise oui non ce n'est pas la question
j'essaie d'y penser mais je vous dis ce
que je pense
le ce que je pense profondément c'est
que nous devons avoir une gamme de peine
qui fait que le magistrat doit être
libre libre de choses non pas qu'il ne
l'ait pas intellectuellement mais libre
concrètement lorsqu'il a un prévenu en
face de lui de choisir la peine qu'il
veut lui appliquer ces soit
l'emprisonnement ces intelligences et un
placement sous bracelet électronique
c'était l'autre situation
il doit pouvoir utiliser l'outil dont il
a besoin aujourd'hui pour des raisons
souvent matériel souvent concrètes il
sait plus combien il ya de bracelets
électroniques de libre il n'a pas d'
enquêtes de personnalité suffisante au
moment où le prévenu se présente devant
lui donc la solution de facilité c'est
je le mets en prison alors même que il
pense peut-être qu'une autre peine 8 été
plus judicieuse donc non la peine
d'emprisonnement n'est pas une peine un
secondaire loin de là elle n'est pas une
peine marginal c'est une pelle comme une
autre qui doit être utilisé à bon
escient ma job durant l'année mais
emmanuel macron a plaidé pour la
contravention nalisation davantage de
contraventionnelle isation qu'elle
délivre justement nous travaillons là
dessus
nous travaillons sur ce sujet là il y a
vous le savez pour les délits routiers
il y a déjà eu un basculement sur des
contrats mentionna lisation nous
travaillons également là dessus pour
délit de consommation de stupéfiants
il y a d'ailleurs eu une mission
parlementaire qui a travaillé sur ce
sujet dont je vais avoir les conclusions
prochainement vous y est favorable
oui oui bien sûr bien sûr alors après je
suis pas encore au moment où nous
parlons capable de vous dire exactement
la forme que cela prendra mais bien sûr
que nous voulons aller vers cela dans la
question
dernière question dans le cadre un petit
mobilier précision dans le cadre des
procédures civiles ont plaidé pour
davantage de médiation et vous pouvez
vous nous dire un mot sur le rôle de la
fonction de médiateur qui va pouvoir
l'exercer à occulter je crois que c'est
très difficile aujourd'hui de vous dire
exactement qui quant à kehl dans quel
mais nous
souhaitons effectivement développé ce
qu'on appelle les marde j'ai découvert
cet acronyme les modes alternatifs de
règlement des différends parmi lesquels
la conciliation la médiation et suivant
les situations je pense qu'il ya des
nous pouvons là aussi faire appel à des
médiateurs différents j'ai une petite
question sur l'âge de non consentement
sexuel est ce que vous êtes toujours
favorable à 13 ans ou est-ce que vous
vous ralliez ou 15 ans quoique que le
chef de l'état évoqué s'ils voulaient -
là dessus je n'ai jamais été affirmative
oui bien sûr mais aujourd'hui j'ai dis
simplement il y a des possibilités
différentes les pays européens utiliser
cet outil avec des âges différents
l'âge de 15 ans moi je pensais 13 ans si
vous voulez parce que je me dis juste si
vous me donnez une seconde en plus je me
dis simplement que s'il ya un rapport
amoureux entre une jeune fille de 14 ans
et 11 mois est un jeune homme de 18 ans
et un mois que ce rapport dégénère qu'il
y ait des accusations qui sont ensuite
portés dire que forcément il y aurait
une prévention non consentement à l'âge
de 15 ans était peut-être un peu tard
mais j'entends parfaitement parfaitement
que l'on puisse me dire que l'âge de 15
ans est un âge plus protecteur et que
cela unifie avec d'autres âge qui
existent je l'entends et je crois que le
parlement là-dessus jouera un rôle
essentiel
merci jérémy dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité madame la ministre
maintenant nous allons parler d'un autre
sujet avec michael ms de public sénat
bonsoir michaëlle jean michel bérard
madame et loubet il y à moi était
promulguée la loi sur la sécurité
intérieure et la lutte contre le
terrorisme
sommes-nous assez protégés aujourd'hui
que répondre est ce que est ce qu'on
peut un jour dire nous sommes assez
protégé vous savez j'ai en mémoire lors
des cérémonies qui ont eu lieu au
bataclan jeu j'ai parlé assez longuement
avec des veuves de victimes du bataclan
qui me faisait part de leur sentiment
permanent de peur et comme je les
comprends d'un point de vue humain
pour autant il me semble que dans la
situation actuelle le gouvernement a
pris des mesures assez puissante de
protection et en termes encore une fois
de prise en charge des personnes qui
arrivent sur notre territoire national
et en termes de contrôle assez renforcé
aux frontières et en termes de
renseignements il me semble qu'il y ait
un suivi très organisée et très fort
alors on a sondé les français sur leur
sentiment évidemment on a tous cette
crainte en commun cette peur partagée
face à ce qui se passe autour de nous
deuxième question donc de notre sondage
opinionway pour l'épreuve de vérité avez
vous le sentiment que les mesures contre
le terrorisme sont suffisantes 39%
insuffisante pour protéger français 59%
sortir de la sécurité même s'il a baissé
oui d'une part il a baissé d'autre part
encore une fois je peux le comprendre
sire que je peux comprendre que à titre
individuel on est un tel sentiment
il me semble qu'en termes de politiques
publiques nous apportons des réponses
permettez moi juste d'ajouter que ces
réponses nous les renforts sont
régulièrement il y à la loi sur la
sécurité intérieure que vous évoquez il
y à des textes qui sont en préparation
il y a les actions que nous conduisons
au quotidien qui ne font pas l'objet
d'un travail législatif et qui sont
peut-être moins connus mais par exemple
nous
ça qu'elle par exemple autour des
préfets se réunissent régulièrement des
groupes de travail qui vont inclure les
procureurs l'ensemble des services de
renseignement pour exactions sur un
territoire si blake en termes
législatifs on est arrivé au maximum de
ce qu'on pouvait faire aujourd'hui
je crois que beaucoup a été fait je
crois qu'on pourra plus aller plus loin
que cela ça me semble difficile
bon sinon c'est quoi c'est la fin d'un
état de droit que vous en parliez tout à
l'heure
moi je crois beaucoup à l'état de droit
oui quand on est hier soir j'ai eu un
débat extrêmement intéressant au sénat
sur le retour des djihadistes et
évidemment les sénateurs me disais mais
qu'est ce qu'on va faire des terroristes
qui vont sortir de prison avant nous
sommes ma réponse est que nous sommes
dans un état dans un état de droit que
une peine a été prononcée que
lorsqu'elle a été exécuté la personne
doit quitter le lieu de détention ce qui
ne veut pas dire qu'elle va dans la
nature gambader il y a bien entendu tout
un suivi qui est mis en place autour de
ces personnes j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire les services pénitentiaires donne
une fiche de renseignements extrêmement
précises à l'ensemble des services de
police de gendarmerie et des services de
renseignement donc évidemment tout est
mis en place pour prévenir une
éventuelle récidive
je crois que beaucoup d'effet alors on
écoute là justement sur ce thème madame
la ministre
la sénatrice que vous avez donc
rencontré hier soir esther benbassa qui
est rattachée au groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes et
qui évoque la réinsertion des revenants
elle parle des femmes et des enfants en
écoute
j'aimerais bien que vous ne donniez
et une réponse programmatique général
est assez précises pour qu'on sage
qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir ces
personnes qui rentrent je parle pas des
combattants bien sûr mais de ses formes
et et ses enfants autant réponse alors
je connais bien la sénatrice benbassa
que j'ai eu l'occasion de recevoir
notamment pour ses travaux autour de la
déradicalisation même s'il est
évidemment face à marmande qu'elles
soient en prison et non mais ce jour-là
d'abord je vais bien je vais maintenant
aller on entend certains hommes
politiques dire mais on n'a pas envie
qui revient aussi tomber ça oui je
l'entends mais moi je considère que la
france n'a pas de politique proactive
pour faire revenir ces personnes mais
que quand elles reviennent quand elles
reviennent elles sont dès leur arrivée
sur le sol français
elles sont immédiatement judiciariser
présenté à un juge
les sommes placées en garde à vue les
femmes également son judiciariser et les
enfants aussi
tous sont judiciariser et une décision
adaptée est prise au cas par cas c'est
pour ça que contrairement à ce que dit
madame la sénatrice benbassa j'ai pas de
solution généralisée a proposé j'ai une
solution au cas par cas refermer cette
au cas par cas
nous avons actuellement dans nos
statistiques 244 personnes majeures qui
sont revenus 68 femmes je crois que j'ai
à peu près je n'ai plus en tête et les
mousses et 56 mineurs en plus tous sont
judiciariser tous pains n'échappe à
notre à notre suivi qui évidemment est
loin des radars a pas du tout aimé vous
entendent également ce que nous
entendons également c'est à dire une
justice spéciale est-ce qu'il faut
établir cette justice spéciale pour les
retours des terroristes mais il y a que
ces jeunes il y à déjà ils sont tous
présentés au parquet antiterroriste qui
vous le savez se situe à paris c'est un
parquet spécial à marie donc il y avait
ce n'est pas une justice spéciale sur
justice qui est organisée de manière
singulière
c'est pas une justice spéciale au sens
de justice d'exception mais c'est une
justice qui est d'organiser de manière
singulière santé justice d'exception ça
pourrait être envisageable ou par non
pardon je répète quand on garde des
sceaux je n'aime pas ce terme là une
justice organisé et adapté de manière
spéciale
oui justice d'exception alors dans le
projet de loi notamment pour lutter
contre le terrorisme
rachida dati ancienne garde des sceaux
avait dit il il ya peu de temps qu'il y
avait deux grands absents dans votre loi
notamment c'est la radicalisation et les
prisons et la radicalisation bien
évidemment en prison est ce que vous
l'avez rassuré depuis je suis pas eu
l'occasion de la rassurer physiquement
mais je suis certaine qu'elle aura été
rassurés par l'ensemble des mesures que
nous prenons le traitement de la
radicalisation en prison vous le savez
je ne sais pas si j'ai le temps ici le
détail est à nouveau nom je suis en tout
cas il fait l'objet là aussi au cas par
cas d'un suivi extrêmement puissant une
période sur le sujet d'inquiétude
majeure pour une période d'évaluation
des gens qui arrivent on les évalue puis
on les place dans des établissements
différenciés selon leur degré de
dangerosité
puis ils font l'objet d'un traitement
adapté est par ailleurs en toutes
circonstances nous avons développé le
service de renseignement pénitentiaire
qui nous permet un suivi en prison par
nos équipes pénitentiaire notre sujet si
vous le permettez au sujet d'une
entreprise franco suisse de lafarge
selon une enquête notamment de nos
confrères du monde cimentier holcim anti
absolument coupable d'avoir versé des
contreparties aux groupes terroristes
des échanges entre 2011 et 2015 pour se
protéger et c'est une ong qui l'accusent
d' entrave à la justice
est ce que la justice française que vous
représentez pourraient se
nous avons se mêler avec cette ong
d'avoir une procédure entre une équipe
ok ok il ya là ça m'ennuie de répondre
parce que c'est ce sont des choses qui
sont actuellement en cours et donc ça
m'ennuie d'avoir une part le public sur
ce sujet là si on peut pas aller un
petit peu plus loin sur ce groupe parce
que non je ne souhaite pas aller un
petit peu plus loin sur les responsables
le groupe d'être griffe véritablement
avec la justice est un devoir de soutien
doivent être coopératifs ou les palais
un peu plus loin
alors je vous parlais de recrutement les
justices recrute actuellement notamment
des surveillants de prisons des
greffiers des auditeurs de justice
est-ce que vous lancer véritablement
cette campagne de recrutement de forces
actives et qu'est ce que vous pouvez
dire aux français aujourd'hui qu'ils ont
peut-être un petit peu peur de s'engager
dans ce domaine pour essayer de passer
le pas alors écoutez d'abord nous
recrutons effectivement des personnels
dans tous les domaines je voudrais juste
redire ici que nous sommes un des
budgets puissant en terme de recrutement
nous recrutons du magistrat ou
surveillants de prison je crois que
c'est un métier qui est devant c'est
difficile à la fois c'est un métier qui
est dure mais c'est un métier qui est
dur c'est un métier qui est très humain
c'est à dire que que vous soyez
surveillants de prison où que vous soyez
magistrats ou greffier peu importe vous
êtes directement en contact avec de la
matière humaine et avec des hommes qui
souffrent généralement qu'il soit
coupable ou pas coupable ce n'est pas la
question
donc c'est un métier dur parce que
emotionnellement c'est dur et puis il
est vrai que les conditions de travail
polonais sont d'améliorer son pareil
difficile je le sais est ce que vous
avez trouvé toute votre place dans ce
gouvernement entre d'autres ministres
peut-être on pense au ministre de
l'intérieur on pas que pas que aura pas
y aller en notamment un texte très
important sur les violences sexuelles et
violences sexuelles qui vaut 6 et est
très présente dans les médias ce que
vous vous retrouvez vous avez votre
place au milieu de ce dispositif
c'est d'une part peut-être à vous de le
dire pour ma part au plan personnel je
me sens parfaitement bien et je dois
dire que je travaille en lien
extrêmement étroits avec eux quand vous
me parlez de gérard collomb nous voyons
chaque semaine pour décider de 2,2
points extrêmement concret vous parlez
de marlène schiappa les textes que elle
souhaite porter ce sont des textes
rédigés par les services de la
chancellerie
je suis dans un travail interministériel
très fort très coordonnée et c'est ce
qui me donne toute satisfaction je
n'aime que le travail d'équipé
oui mais vous avez été stupéfiés je
crois lorsqu'en vous a proposé ce poste
aujourd'hui avec quelques mois de recul
qu'est ce que vous vous dites là où vous
êtes
je me dis que c'est un honneur que de
représenter la justice un honneur grave
et c'est aussi une responsabilité très
forte et je souhaite vraiment pouvoir
réussir pas pour moi mais pour les
magistrats et pour les français alors
l'ensemble des personnels du juste vous
avez ouvert d'autres chantiers qu'on
appelait le temps d'évoquer m'ont abordé
beaucoup de questions sur la justice
vous avez réaffirmé le principe de la
majorité numérique à 16 ans on sait pas
comment ça va sera vérifiée sur les
réseaux sociaux
et puis il ya une chambre internationale
de commerce un que vous avez alors qu'il
y ait réussi à ce que la justice ne peut
donc également mais la fusée en faveur
de la france dans le cadre du brics it
ce n'est pas que dans le cadre du bric
si nous affirmons la place de paris dans
le domaine du droit et dans le domaine
international du droit international
donc nous sommes une place très
puissante ça contribue à l'attractivité
de pays merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui on vous remercie
vivement de nous avoir apporté tous ces
éléments d'information effectivement sur
ces réformes importantes merci beaucoup
mais qu'at elle à metz bonsoir à tous la
semaine prochaine et bien sûr le
secrétaire national de la cfdt qui sera
l'invité de l'épreuve de vérité laurent
berger bonsoir à tous soir